à l'occasion des cérémonies d'ouverture
de la coupe du monde de football
plusieurs milliards de téléspectateurs
pourront entendre l'hymne officiel
composé par le sénégalais youssou ndour
qu'il interprète en compagnie de la
chanteuse belge axelle red
youssou ndour l'une des stars de la
musique africaine que nous avons suivi
de los angeles à dakar sa ville
sophie mais elle oui car dans ce studio
de los angeles
youssou ndour et axelle red sont l'objet
de toutes les attentions car le duo est
ici pour un hymne officiel
mais scinder une gamme
je pouvoir cette fois ni toit et des
victoires musicale en duo comme en solo
cela fait dix ans que youssou ndour les
collectionne hors du continent africain
depuis sa rencontre avec peter gabriel
jusqu'à ce nouvel enregistrement avec
axelle red choisi pour devenir la
chanson du mondial de fonds
dakar sénégal ville natale de youssou
ndour une ville fière d'afficher la plus
grande star du plaisir à chaque coin de
rue
ils ont toujours la peau quand je relève
meilleure écoute paraître à bien c'est
le piano je vais te le mettre plus fort
une chanson quand elles existent
au départ elle a besoin d'une voix et
d'un piano seulement pour qu'on se rende
compte que c'est vraiment une chanson
maintenant lettonie je sais ça c'est les
boutons la technique dans son nouveau
studio d'enregistrement le mieux équipé
de toute l'afrique de l'ouest
dieu se peaufine son prochain album une
base traditionnelle sénégalaise mais les
influences occidentales
mais quand le week-end ils se retrouvent
au thiossane sa boîte de nuit du centre
de dakar
il triomphe au roi du mbalax du wolof et
des rythmiques africaines pur et dur
bousculades et foule en délire deux cent
mille personnes descendues dans les rues
quinze mille billets vendus pour un
concert qui fera date le retour de
youssou ndour à saint louis du sénégal
la ville où l'artiste est pour la
première fois monté sur scène il ya 25
ans et qui le célèbrent aujourd'hui un
héros national
un héros national avec rang
d'ambassadeur car à travers ce nouveau
duo comme celui d'il ya quatre ans avec
neneh cherry youssou ndour et ça y est
aussi d'ouvrir les regards sur l'afrique
je pense que ces dernières années
l'afrique dans le cadre du football dans
le cas de la musique elle est assez
présent télé et les prêts télé elle a
envie de monter une image plus positive
qui se passe depuis des années quand
même chez nous
et pour que cette reconnaissance de
l'afrique ne dure pas seulement le temps
d'un refrain ou d'une mi temps après la
sortie de son nouvel album du soul blues
se consacrer aux jeunes talents du
sénégal et qui sait les a menés alors
que ou juste ruent sur les bords du
pacifique